He was a man who was impossible to ignore
the flamboyant character with a cigar
and a $50,000 pinky ring.
Although he weighed over 250 pounds.
He could when the occasion demands or
did move with a lethal speed and force is
generally smile contrasted with the
two scars that streaked across his left
cheek. Then there was his
clothing, his wardrobe.
It was nothing short of outrageous
custom tailored purple suits. Pella,
gray fedoras and diamond
encrusted stick pens.
He loved attention once he'd be able
to adore him even as he ruthlessly
dispatched those who we have no useful.
His name was Al Capone and he has
become the symbol of American greed and
corruption in the 1920s and thirties when
he's eyes on January the 25th of 1947
the New York Times called him a monster
symbol of a disease which was eating
into the consciousness of America about
the paper it went on to say the home was
incredible. The creation
of an evil dream. Yes.
Almost everything that the public
thought they knew about him nams,
the most of us think
we know today is false.
The products of decades of
glorification and mythmaking.
I did today's biographics video.
We're going to peel back the layers
to discover the real al Capone.
Yeah,
no.
Gabrielle and Theresa Component made
the big move from Sicily to New York in
1894 they ended up in a four room at
flat on Park Avenue adjacent to the
Brooklyn Navy Yard with a couple,
had two sons into the youngest
who was just a few months souls.
Third boy followed shortly after
their arrival boulder by trade.
Gabrielle was looking for
a new life in America.
What he found was a city in which
immigrants were viewed as lower citizens,
Italians,
especially with vilified by Americans
who blamed the spiraling crime rates and
there's a New York was experiencing
on them. Yeah. The components,
they were a hard working family.
They were law abiding and trying
to fit in to their new society.
Okay.
When the fourth son Alfonse was born
in 1899 the family had settled into a
decent market, hard existence, life
around the Brooklyn Naval Yard.
It was pretty rough and tumble,
and then by the age of 10 young Al Capone
had begun to exhibit to the toughness
and brashness that he carried into
his adult life. From the start,
Alan merged as a natural leader at the
age of 14 he forms the Navy street gang
in order to protect Italian women from
harassment from the Irish neighbors by
now had been expelled from school for
punching a female teacher in the face.
But you know what he said? Well, she ended
in first just prior to World War One,
the components,
they moved down to the Italian [inaudible]
Gabrielle's head down and get on with
the data team was paying off and it's
Al found himself in an upwardly mobile
middle class.
The university still further up the
hill though was where the really wet off
people left this area. It was strictly
off limits to the likes of the components.
The teenage owl looks upon
this area and via size.
This was where the Rockefellers nibs
and the feisty teaming saw reason why he
couldn't live the Rockefeller wait.
He just got to find a means.
Guesstimate.
By the age of 19 Al had
become a local tough.
He knew how to use a gun and a knife.
He was a big British draw that you could
knock him out into the grounds with a
single punch.
It also finds himself a family.
On December the 30th 1918 he married,
made Kauflin.
It was two years older than him.
Three weeks previously may
have given birth to their son,
Elvis family life and encouraged vein
to get on the straight and narrow,
intense on turning to a respectable
life worthy of his wife and child.
He moved the family out of
the neighborhood and away
from the bad influences.
They shifted the Baltimore and Al took
a job as a bookkeeper. Ironically,
this straight job,
we'd come in handy down the track when
he was juggling millions of dollars and
from bootleg liquor.
Now that could have been the end of the
story for our phones and make your pain.
They could have settled into an uneventful
life of respectability in Baltimore.
Maybe even work their way up the social
ladder to gain some community status.
But wow.
Allows we well know that wasn't it.
Yeah.
With a sudden death of his
father of a heart attack,
Al's flirtation with
respectability. Well, it was over.
He returned for the funeral
and soon found that the family,
we're now looking to him for guidance
as well as financial support that would
require more money than he was earning
as a bookkeeper in Baltimore. Meanwhile,
the local gang that Al had pulled away
from an outgrowth of the Manhattan based
five points, gang, they were at a
crossroads six months earlier and Afi,
a big wig in Chicago named big Jim
Coliseum have been shot dead and leader of
the gang.
That component pulled away from Johnny
Toria was intent on stepping into the
vacuum created by big gyms demise.
He invited component to join him
as his right hands, man. Sorry.
You had been grooming component
for the last couple of years.
They'd given him a job as a collector to
ensure extortion payments were made. Oh,
he soon graduated to become
the main bouncer and bartender
at the Harvard Inn on
Coney island.
Okay.
Now it was one line to this established
and then the dowels hold Avion or patron
that she had a nice rear ends.
The girl's brother, well,
she doesn't take so kindly to the
remark and in an instant had carved up
Capone's face with a bottle open
up for the rest of his life.
Our would carry dual stripes down his
cheek giving rise to the name Scarface.
Yeah.
Now,
while they had been in Baltimore,
rumors had circulated an owl had
been involved in a couple of murders.
One prostitute,
he was suspected of withholding pin money,
and the other was a friend who'd
reneged on a gambling debt.
All of this was bringing unwanted
police attention to the gang,
and shortly after his father's funeral,
deponent was called to a meeting with
lucky Luciano, a key member of the gang.
So what's going on now?
It's it to avast nervously.
I'll tell you what's going on.
Ac on her applied,
you're going to get the hell out of town.
Don't bother to pack Lucy on Luciana.
He then handed out an envelope which
contained $2,000 which is about $25,000 in
today's money and directed him to go
straight to grand central station had for
Chicago.
Right.
I'll arrived in Chicago in 1921 ready,
willing and eager to none the rights.
He left his wife and maybe behind in
Brooklyn with instructions to follow one
set established then you life.
The challenge now for Johnny Tario,
the leader of the gang was to get an al
Capone to stop using his fists and start
using his brains in order
to succeed in the rackets.
He put Capone in the position of head
bouncer and bartender at the Ford uses a
four story building which serves
as Torreos general officers,
which also housed a saloon and a cafe.
The top floor of this establishment,
well that was a brothel and Al apparently
spent quite a lot of time on that
floor where he wasn't exactly working.
Indeed,
his sexual proclivities resulted
in a lifelong battle with syphilis.
Okay.
This,
it was no place for the weak of heart.
Countless unsolved murders took place
there with al playing a leading hand in
dispatching those who tario
wanted to eliminate it. In fact,
Adelaide did so well within the year
that he was made a partner sharing in the
$100,000 annual profits.
Now it's Oreo talk about how to portray
an air of respectability even as he
delved deeper and deeper into
the underworld. As a cover,
our opens a secondhand
furniture store next door.
He carry business cards announcing
his occupation as furniture dealer.
As Chicago authorities began to crack
down and organized crime Torrio spread his
business interests into the
suburbs and the suburbs.
Local police and politicians, well,
they can be controlled more easily.
In fact,
it was torreos expansion beyond Chicago.
That was the key to the development of
the empire that Capone would eventually
inherit. By the time component
arrived in the windy city. Sorry,
I had already set up vice gambling and
prostitution operations in the nearby
town of Burnham. Then with the
election of crime busting Chicago.
Now William need divine.
In October of 1923 the entire base of
the operation was moved to the western
suburb of road.
The plan was to make Cicero a
wide open town, whether again,
good pedal booze and accommodate
gamblers at will to do so sorry.
He reached an agreement
with the authorities to shut
down his brothels in Cicero
so long as he had free reign on the
other two arms of his business by cutting
the police and politicians
in on the profits.
Johnny soon develops the operation he
wants us within six months of moving in.
The outfit owns the town of
Cicero, lock, stock, and barrel.
Why
January of 1924 Tory,
I felt so confident in his position that
he embarks on a trip back to the old
country when he planned to set his mother
up in a fine home in Venice and this
absence would be in charge.
Alice fest challenges to make sure that
the officials who had his back, well,
that they stayed in office,
the local elections were to be
held in April and component,
was prepared to go to any lengths to
keep the incumbents in office. Well,
what's the way Al Capone?
You would do this? Well,
that would be by bringing some extra
muscle. He brought his two older brothers,
Ralph and frank over from New York.
The brothers thought nothing of destroying
balance and replacing them with votes
for that own candidates.
Everyone kind of just went along with
whatever the Capones did. The police,
the sheriff,
even the state's attorney,
they all went along with this apparently
deciding that it was futile to try and
pose them. On the day of the
election and Cicero tario Capone,
gangsters used guns and
fists to intimidate voters,
escorting them to the ballot box and
watching them drop their votes for the
incumbent mayor directly into the
box on his polar watches and election
officials were held captive until after
the ballot closed on honest citizens as
well. Obviously they were
outraged at this. Some of
them even cools upon Chicago.
Judge Edmond DG Iraqi to do something
about the Cicero gang directly deputized
70 Chicago cops. He went into Cicero in
plain clothes and unmarked black sedans.
They seem spotted frank Capone on the
street going in down Widleen his body with
bullets.
When our heard about
his brothers sleeping,
all of the sophistication that Tario
had imbued him over the last year was
ripped away. His savage nature was
unleashed as he vowed to take revenge.
It's a goal of torreos persuasive
skill to keep it in check,
but I he was not able to keep Capone
out of a spotlight staying in the
backgrounds having als mines. It cost
them life of his brother. Sorry. No,
he continued to preach nonviolence.
You're resorting to brute force when all
else fails, but the name of Al Capone,
well that was synonymous with violence.
This is something that's pretty well
illustrated in contemporary culture.
We've got a clip here,
thanks to boardwalk empire
pretty nicely sums up
how we see al Capone.
Now try as he might to
follow these leaders.
Advice component was plagued by mayhem
and a temporary found difficult to
control.
AL's based nature was combative rather
than diplomatic and it resulted in an
awful lot of bloodshed in
the years that were to come.
Alice pent up emotions over the
death of his brother. Frank,
we're given expression on the evening of
May the eighth I'm 1924 his partner in
a prostitution ring jacket music had
been roughed up by an Irish target named
Joe Howard fault,
refusing him alone,
composing immediately tracked down
Howard in a bar and demanded to know what
it's happens.
Howard took one look and Capone calls him
a Daigo pimp and then told them to get
lost.
At this point is Capone pulls out his
pistol and shot Howard in the face and he
did this in front of dozens of witnesses.
The more it never convicted out for
this breeze is murder, but the press,
they sat and he did the original
story identifying him as our Brown,
but when it was picked up by other papers,
it was corrected to Alphonse component.
This was really the beginning of his
public persona and when he became famous
for it,
less than a year later in January of
1925 Johnny Tario was ambushed by rival
gang members.
He came within an inch of losing his
life surviving and we need to have a nine
month prison terms slapped on him
for operating an illegal brewery.
While so he decided that he'd had
enough of the Chicago madness.
By the end of that year,
it completely handed the reins
over to Capone and he disappeared.
Okay.
He inherited the goals of mine from
Johnny Tario that was fueled by a highly
organized operation that operated
largely behind the scenes. In fact,
the duplicity was so complete that 99%
of the citizens of Cicero never even saw
a gangster,
rather than I'll be used the government
to control the area with noncompliant
merchants being plagued with higher taxes
and loss of parking in front of their
stores, but they quickly got the
message and they got into line
now component set his sights on the north
side of Chicago to make some headway.
He first had to subjugate the
deadliest gang Chicago ever known.
The generous they operated in the open,
even having police protection.
The Jenna's also had been major
suppliers of alcohol to the Tario Capone
[inaudible] and it's Capone heard even
supported them in their battles with
other gangs. But after crushing
the rivalry, Banyan Gang,
the Germans decided to take
over the Capone empire.
It would prove to be their undoing.
The Jenna's selected a couple of
Sicilians to assassinate Capone,
however it recognizing
components power and fearful.
That's such an attempt would
lead to that own demise.
The Sicilian duo informed Capone
of the Jenna's intentions,
how convinced them to turn on
the janitors and in short order,
they had killed three of the Gen ed
brothers, the remaining three brothers,
while they fled to Sicily
with the Jana as well.
They were out of the way to play it now,
how to deal with the survivors of the
O'bannon gang who had rated components,
headquarters and number of times on one
particular occasion there to use eight
touring costs.
They first shot blanks to newer people
outside and then followed with a live
ammunition like kill the
Capone on the spot. There is,
well, it didn't work though.
Over 1000 rounds were fired.
Miraculously. No one was killed.
I was convinced that the brain's buying
this attempted hit was Hymie Weiss
leader of the Albanian gang. Anti
immediately ordered the death of this man.
They hit men,
set themselves up across from Weiss's
flower shop and waited and waited and
waited. After a week they finally
spotted Weiss walking towards his shop.
They killed him and free of his body
guards successfully stepping into the
vacuum created by the killing of Hymie.
Weiss was bugs.
Moron who was eager to get rid
of Capone as why is it been more,
has plenty of guts but little common
sense. He publicly denounced hipbone,
especially for paddling bad women and
bad alcohol constantly on the attack.
Moran's troops launched in number of
forays against Capone's businesses.
By February of 1929
campaign has had enough.
He ordered a massive hit on Capone to
take place on some Valentine's date
because this guy is does policemen and
did Moran's warehouse and caught the
seven victims off guard facing them
towards the wall as if they're going to
frisk them. They then move them
down with machine gun. Fire
around was not among them this attack,
but it was enough to scare him off.
Having eliminates is all opposition
on the north side of Chicago.
Deponent now focused on the south after
a number of killings. His rivals, well,
they sued for peace, agreeing to give
owl in large slice of their operation.
My March of 1929 Al Capone,
he was the undisputed king of Chicago
being portrayed to the public as the
ultimate Gangsta.
Yet at the same time he was being
read the riot acts by his peers.
The years the leaders of organized crime
had been holding annual meetings to
discuss matters of mutual concern. Now
the matter of mutual concern, well,
it was what to do with Al Capone.
Al Had attracted a tremendous amount
of unwanted attention with the St
Valentine's Day massacre.
He was bringing too much unwanted
attention as the king as well.
All the time had come for
him to be neutralized.
The commission decreed that Joseph,
Elio and old enemy of Capone would be
put in place in Chicago to keep our in
check. The poem would also have
to see it as gambling operations.
To the commission.
Capone was privately outraged that the
condition was muzzling him in this way,
but he was also smart enough
to know that if he protested,
he would quickly be eliminated.
He decided to take the advice of the
commission and line no for awhile and just
wash that away to safety line
low than from inside a jail cell.
Within 16 hours of coming out to the
commission meeting component had been
arrested for carrying a concealed weapon.
Deponent trusted is $50,000 diamond pinky
ring to his attorney with instructions
to give it to his brother Ralph, who would
become acting hedges until he returns.
He then began a 12 month JL town when
he emerged from his prison cell in March
of 1930 the pine discovered that
the climate's, it had changed.
He had been listed as public
enemy number one by the FBI.
The federal government now considered
him a menace to society and was prepared
to do anything to put
him behind bars for good.
It was certain that Al was violating
the Volstead act by selling liquor,
but they were not able to prove it. Not
even Elliot Ness. Auntie's untouchables,
were able to stop the pain.
Finally,
the FBI decided that their best chance
at putting the phone away was to
convicted of tax evasion,
was used to being cheered when
he attended public events,
but now that the government was bringing
income tax evasion charges against him
crowds, they started booing. Yeah.
What's worse is formerly failproof
methods of fixing the outcomes of trials.
They were having no effects. Owl did
manage to bribe several jury members,
but on the day of the trial,
the judge switched the jury panel.
From that moment on,
Virginia's were sequestered and they
were out of Al's reach after presenting a
damaged case, which highlighted
a life of lavish spending,
yet virtually no tax payments.
The prosecution concluded by reminding
the jury that Capone was no Robin Hood.
He spent wildly on himself and his
cronies doing nothing to help the poor and
the down and out.
The judge found him guilty on three
counts of tax evasion and on October the
24th 1931 he was sentenced
to 11 years in prison.
This was the harshest sentence ever
handed down for tax evasion Capone. Well,
he felt that now his gangland
associates would rally to his age,
but he just didn't get it.
Maybe it has advancing syphilis.
It's something to do with this,
but the reality was that had been artfully
shunted aside at the Atlantic City
meeting in 1929 now two years later,
it was life was out in the open for all
to see and he had a felony conviction to
his name. He was anathema to his format
gangland buddies. They ignored it.
Deponent spent most of his time in an
Atlanta prison and then spent the last
three years of his sentence of Alcatraz.
By then his syphilis,
it's serious and eroded
his mental faculties.
By the time he died of cardiac arrest
on January the 25th of 1947 doctors
concluded that he had the mind
of a 12 year old child and well,
that was all for hours.
Bye
Not. We'd love to know what
you think of this video.
Please leave us a comment
below and if he did like it,
why not subscribe or share
this video with a friends?
We're going to be publishing two
videos a week just like this.
And also please do leave a like if you
like this, and as always, thanks for
Shank.